>> I've found that really understanding what the interpreter is doing when it
executes my code and understanding variable scope and
closures, really helps me in writing concise applications that
other developers can easily read through and understand.
How can our students use these features to their advantage in
writing their own code?
>> Well, it should become much clearer when we get to later lessons,
where we start writing functions that would return objects with methods on them.
Meaning, functions that are stored as properties of the object.
But more generally,
any time you see a function with an input parameter that's quite static.
Meaning, you don't expect the parameter to take on a new value every time you
call the function.
That's an opportunity to re-factor your code,
such that you store the value in a variable from an outer scope.
Because of the way closures work, the inner function will always have access to
the outer scope variable even after the outer function returns.
Like I said, we are going to see plenty of examples of this in
the upcoming lessons.